after Cash Cab all the sudden people
like we could be filling seven cars
alright mr. Ben Bailey I know this is no
cab I figured we'd do this interview in
my car you know stay put just for safety
reasons you know but uh
ashin I come on we are the biggest Cash
Cab fans that's awesome we're stoked
it's back well my next contestants don't
realize is that not only are they about
to step into the Cash Cab but they're
gonna be joined by a celebrity or debunk
some Cash Cab myths of how many yes sir
the first one is at this point do people
recognize you like when they get into
your cab with a real L when we're
shooting alright we try to you know we
turned it through our best to keep them
from figuring out that it's maybe in
minutes the Cash Cab but now like this
last season you know I do this thing
where I like now they recognize that
they're still people pick him up you
pick up a crowd full of tourists but
then you also have the New Yorkers who
just want to freaking get somewhere to
be is it on your mind that like people's
lives or benefits they get the same tag
I don't go fast several points on my
license because I'm what they call an
aggressive driver
oh are you ever driving around New York
and you're mid question and then someone
just says something so bonkers yeah like
I would start screaming New York as if
it might be an insurance risk yeah I
think I'm high risk if you put them all
together there's probably like a four
DVD boxset of outtakes of me shouting
obscenities that other driver
it just happens it's not like you know
anyone would have those moments when
you're driving in New York City the best
ones would be the ones where someone's
shouting at me because I'm like kind of
getting away with a little something or
whatever and then they recognized me so
they're like you hey are you important
question do you worry you'll ever run
out of accents I do actually that's a
really good question who is the drunkest
person who's ever gotten in the Cash Cab
besides me the driver had some pretty
drunk people in there but usually we
could we kind of weed them out you're
right like before there even gave this
isn't gonna work
you know everybody's like you should
pick up drunk people to be so much more
fun but I'm like it's a brunch the
mimosa brunch brunch Oh peace water is
great on camera right we've done it
other rights free yeah see Diane if you
made it to the video bonus you already
got to where you're headed Steph have
you ever had to drop someone off in like
though weird like the worst part of town
cuz they get out and you're like sorry
the only one time I did not do that is I
was actually driving in there's a tunnel
that runs under First Avenue and these
two ladies
struck out slow down and they just went
why do you have like a dream list of
celebs you'd want to play Cash Cab I
want Ken Jennings in the Cash Cab
sounds like a season finale wrapping it
up here what is your favorite memory of
Cash Cab most favorite memory is easy
it's Times Square again we're shooting
b-roll so there's no contestants and
they have it's just me driving and I
realized we're not we haven't been
moving for a while when I start I'm
looking around like and people are gonna
someone's gonna spot me sitting here
sure enough I see a guy standing right
out of here
when it is sheer just like I mean Times
Square was packed yeah you could hear
this chair just erupt through the whole
crowd and I put my hand out the window
and I roared and I was like this might
be the best
[Music]
you